how's it going people
i am a tan arrested
and are ready to roll dave rubin not
arrested
a rested dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message for
today
2 22 20 21
there's some sort of symmetry and that i
am just back
from the free state of florida
and i'm feeling good i am back in the
authoritarian hellhole known as
california but there are some signs that
that could be changing we'll talk about
that in a little bit
and before i do anything else guys quick
uh click that subscribe
button over there on the youtube there's
a little notification bell make sure
you're
seeing these videos as you know we are
live every day
at 11 a.m pacific that is 2 p.m eastern
and we're now doing that friday panel
show every friday we're adding in some q
and a's and a whole bunch of other stuff
and uh yeah as a rested guy
i am uh very excited to be back i had a
great 10 days it was sort of a
it was a half working vacation we
actually did put up a whole bunch of
videos
uh because i know you guys can't go
through the day
without at least hearing me say one
thing right at least what
without watching one video of me doing
something so we had our interview
uh with heather mcdonald from the
manhattan institute was up
last week and we did a bunch of
presidents day videos
that we had shot before and we put those
up and we did our friday panel all on
critical race theory and all that good
stuff that's all stuff that happened
last week
while it was happening i was on the
beach i was relaxing if you guys are in
the reuben report community you saw
pictures of me
with pelicans and with alligators and
with lizards and other
assorted things i wanted to tell you
guys uh two stories
uh of things that happened in florida
because as i said it was partly
a working vacation so i'll tell you the
the
more serious one first and then i'll
tell you the funny one um
so one night i was on the southwest
coast of florida in an undisclosed
location
and uh one night we got a call that um
there were a bunch of
investors who wanted to meet us in miami
now investors for locals obviously
and if you haven't been playing along
san francisco which once was the
the home of silicon valley and was the
hub of the
the tech world really and that's where
all the innovation came from and
everything else
um it's basically crumbling they've
turned it into a progressive hellhole
crime is through the roof homelessness
drug use the rest of it the last time i
was in san francisco i mean it was it
was
actually disgusting i saw more than one
person just
literally shooting up on the street it
was it was not
pretty that i was actually there like
three or four days
before the lockdowns began right when
the economy like tanked right at the
beginning of covet i know
even though that's less than a year ago
it feels like a lifetime ago so we
actually did
our first run of fundraising like
literally as the economy was tanking and
it all ended up working out for us
um and good things are happening but in
any event san francisco's crumbling and
miami and florida
as a state but miami as a city
particularly is just absolutely
exploding
they are moving there in droves and as
many people pretty much everyone that i
talked to that was a native floridian
said to me
they're like you know it's great that
you guys are coming here and we're very
happy that you like our freedom and our
open restaurants and all that good stuff
but don't bring any of that lefty
nonsense here and
man i i don't i don't live there yet but
i would say yeah
florida should consider building a wall
or something because it's like you want
good people to come right and i think
the mayor of miami is doing a really
uh good job of this like welcoming
people
saying hey we want new industries we
want to be a tech hub miami's a truly
international city
it's like let san francisco crumble with
their leftist policies and like
let great things happen in miami but you
could really
feel it i mean i'm really not
exaggerating when i say this almost
everybody that i talked to when they
would say you know where you from what's
going on
it was like oh man well first off they
would always oh you live in l.a are you
okay you know it's like i survived a
while you aren't right
are you all right like like there was
some sort of like nuclear bomb that went
off here
um they can't believe that people still
live why do you live there what are you
doing the taxes the government
the whole thing um so if you live in
florida
i would i would be very welcoming of the
new people but this
is a real moment for those of us that
are liberty-minded conservative whatever
you want to call it at this point
to really stand up for our values people
are flowing
out of those terrible leftist cities
san francisco portland seattle la et
cetera they're going to the good places
right
but that means you got to respect some
of the stuff and acknowledge that some
of the red states
and these more red cities uh have done
some things right and not try to change
everything there so i think some
some floridians are worried about that
but hopefully the people that move will
realize that anyway
so we drove across the state we drove
across alligator alley that's what they
call it if you drive right across the
southern part of florida it's alligator
alley because there's alligators
everywhere i think there's
basically all they have is like florida
state penitentiaries there's not much
there
there's also a panther like pavilion or
a panther nursery whatever you want to
call it
so there's a lot of warnings for
panthers so you're driving something
you're driving down something called
alligator alley
watching out for alligators and then you
see all these signs for watch out for
the panthers
anyway we survived that we get to miami
we have this dinner with a bunch of
investors
um it went extremely well and the reason
i'm mentioning all of this is because
during
the meeting this is a this is a public
thank you to anyone that took part in
this
uh during the meeting we you know we're
telling them about locals
our numbers are great the growth is
great all this good stuff
but you know we're trying to raise funds
like that that's what it is these are
not funds that pay me these are funds to
grow
the company we're doing this and i said
you know what instead of me just selling
selling you guys on this why don't i
post in my locals community right now
why don't i post about what
is going on here why people are joining
us how we're doing
social media different how we're
cleaning it up why it's better blah blah
and i said i'm going to post it i'm not
even going to look at it i'm just going
to hand my phone around the table
well that's exactly what i did i posted
it and then everyone that's part of my
local community they get a push
notification
and within about 10 minutes we had over
300 people explaining why
the reuben report community and locals
is great and how there's no bots and
trolls
and you can share opinions and it's
pleasant and all this good stuff
and we just handed it around the table
and uh long story short
we've got some new investors and i'm i'm
super excited
and for any of you that took part in
that i just want to give you
uh a thank you and uh how cool and i
you know i said by the way i said i was
like be as brutally honest
as you want to be and it's hard you know
when's the last time you just handed
your phone to a bunch of strangers i
mean i just handed
my phone to these people and i let them
all look at it and people started
reading them at the table it was
it was pretty great so i was psyched
about that anyway spent most of the time
on the other coast of florida and i want
to tell you one funny story because
um you know we were we were eating food
at restaurants and things and we'd have
drinks also at these restaurants it's
really wild what you can do in a free
state
and one night we were there with uh with
my sister and my brother-in-law and the
kids and we're
we're having dinner and you know even in
florida by the way
the waiters and the waitresses and the
bartenders and things
they have to wear masks you as a patron
don't they kind of you know
if you're sitting you don't have to wear
a mask they kind of want you to if
you're
if you're like walking between tables or
going to the bathroom but everyone does
what they think is right and you guys
know my feelings on that that's sort of
the way we have to
go ahead with this that's just my
personal belief and you can have your
own personal belief
anyway something fairly hilarious
happened which is you know
we're sitting in this restaurant and my
sister's got two young kids and they're
they're just great and we're having a
ball
and this elderly couple florida it's a
lot of old people
and despite all the old people by the
way the second oldest uh populist
in the united states their their
mortality numbers are way down even
though they kept everything open
although mainstream media doesn't seem
to want to talk about that
anyway there's a lot of old people in
florida a lot of old people having
dinner this very elderly couple i would
say these two were
probably between 85
and 90. they come up to the table and
they're telling oh the kids are so great
that's so great you're on vacation where
are you from blah blah and the woman
points to my nephew and she's standing
right behind me
she starts pointing to my nephew and
says oh you're so cute and as she's
saying it i turn around
and she stuck her finger like
right in my mouth and like it was an old
woman she couldn't move very quick and i
was kind of
and she like literally got like oh
an all-over saliva dripping
all over her finger you know there
wasn't much taste to it she was very old
there wasn't like a lot of juice or
anything
on the finger anyway i just thought it
was hilarious that i end up not only do
i go to a restaurant in florida
i had the parmesan crusted sea bass
quite delicious by the way although i
ate mostly grouper throughout the week
but not only did i go to a restaurant i
survived but then an
elderly woman actually stuck her finger
in my mouth
and and guess what everybody's okay as
far as i know she's okay i didn't trade
numbers with her but i think she's okay
and and i'm okay and life goes on so
good things happening in florida less
good things happening here
although because we didn't do a show
last week you may not have heard
that uh california has got
the 1.5 million signatures to
recall our horrifically awful
governor gavin newsom you still have we
still have till may
sorry until march 16th to get more and
the thing is you really want to go way
over the 1.5 because you know they're
going to do everything they can
to make sure that the signatures don't
count or whatever so my hope is we get
it to like 1.8 1.9
but i think recalling this buffoon who
then can run again
and hopefully there'll be a great set of
people that will run against him hint
rick grinnell if you're watching this
thing
i'll campaign for you um and we're gonna
do a whole show by the way
on the the california recall we're into
a panel in a couple days
um but if we get rid of this guy
it might start the domino effect that's
what everybody's waiting for right
it has become so obvious that certain
states in the union
in this great union this great country
certain states
do it right do it basically right maybe
there's no truly right but basically
right
and certain states really do it wrong
and and the states that are run by these
buffoons like andrew cuomo
and gavin newsom they're doing it really
really wrong and by the way now it looks
like the feds might be looking into
some of the things that andrew cuomo did
um as far as putting people back in
nursing homes and the rest of it so
anyway
anyway i think truly that if we can if
we can recall this guy
that and then and then not only recall
him you got to recall him which we're
going to do but then
maybe get a new governor that maybe we
can start the domino effect
of getting rid of all of these
authoritarian lunatics i think it's
possible
i'm a dreamer but i'm not the only one
all right guys before we get to the
stories
i want to talk to you about ancestry.com
you know there are many paths to finding
your family story and whichever way you
choose
tracing your family generations back
with a family tree
or uncovering your ethnicity with
ancestry dna
it's easy to get started with ancestry
you could find a famous relative or
perhaps a photo of your great grandma as
a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history
and yourself after all the story of your
family is the story of you
with the ongoing pandemic it's easy to
feel disconnected from your loved ones
i've been talking about that a lot
but researching your history is a fun
activity the whole family can enjoy
and the stories you learn about your
shared past can bring you closer
together we've done a massive family
tree in my family and it's pretty
awesome i think i've mentioned this
we've tracked my mom's family back even
into the 1700s late 1700s at this point
pretty amazing stuff
ancestry dna can reveal ethnic origins
and provide historical details
that bring unique family stories to life
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but can also
pinpoint specific regions within them
giving you insightful geographic detail
about your history
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
and learn how
and why your family moved from place to
place around the world
no other dna test delivers such a unique
interactive experience
grab an ancestry dna kit and start a
free trial to amplify your discoveries
with ancestry's billions of records
start exploring your family story today
head to my url
ancestry.com reuben to get your ancestry
dna kit
and start your free trial that's
ancestry.com
ruben and now back to me all right
let's talk about cnn a little bit
and uh and dr fauci or the infallible
fouchy
as i call him so i tried not to pay that
much attention
to the news while i was i wasn't i
wasn't off the grid but i was trying to
like you know actually be on
the beach actually i got you know you
get that weekly reminder on your phone
of like how much
phone time you've been doing and my
phone was down 72
last week like that that's how you know
you're having a good week uh well the
infallible falchi
was on cnn with dana bash
and uh if you thought we were returning
to normalcy in 2021 if you thought
2020 was the bad year remember that's
what everyone was saying a month ago oh
oh we 2020 is behind us everything's
gonna be fine in 2021.
well fouchy he's pushing this thing into
2022
let's take a look who and the president
have suggested that will approach
normality toward the end of the year
what does normal mean
do you think americans will still be
wearing masks for example in 2022.
you know i think it is possible that
that's the case and again
it really depends on what you mean by
normality
exactly the way
no dana it's important because if
normality
means exactly the way things were before
we had this happen to us i i mean i
can't predict that
i mean obviously i think we're going to
have a significant degree
of normality beyond what the terrible
burden
that all of us have been through over
the last year that as we get into the
fall and the winter
by the end of the year i agree with the
president completely
that we will be approaching a degree of
normality it may or may not be precisely
the way it was
in november of 2019 but it'll be much
much better
than what we're doing right now oh
infallible fouchy
as we get into the fall and winter
as he calls it with his brooklyn accent
the winter
um we may have a degree of normality
it's funny because i remember and i have
a very good memory about these things i
know a lot of people forget
things that's partly what social media
does to us they want us to forget
yesterday and forget the week before and
certainly forget the month before and
before that
but i remember a little less than a year
ago it's it's basically almost a year
now
when you guys were telling us two weeks
to flatten the curve and we did
absolutely everything you told us to do
we've been through this before we were
all
wearing gloves at the supermarket and
washing paper bags
when we got home we all did all that and
now a
possible return to normality in the fall
now i want to be clear again if you want
to wear a mask you should wear a mask
and by the way when i was in florida
although i was mostly on the beach where
people weren't wearing masks
there were some people were wearing
masks and it was their right to do so
and you could maybe judge someone for
wearing a mask on a beach or someone can
wear a mask on the beach
it's up to you to do it but at some
point
uh a return to normality i mean well he
first off he it's
he basically says well it would depend
what you mean by normality i mean i
think normality is long gone if you
think
normal was the world that we had before
this lunacy of the last 11 12 months
well i think that world is gone so i
don't think there will be a return to
normality
the system whatever you want to call it
has has shown us
how how it will do things to
impair our levels of freedom and how it
will make sure we can't go to work
and we have to wear crazy things now
when i was on the flight back i kid you
not when i was on the flight back
american airlines
last night from florida the guy twice
the lead flight attendant twice
announced uh that we should eat in a
timely fashion and that means you can't
eat peanuts one at a time
so they literally want to regulate how
fast you eat your peanuts now i thought
you couldn't even bring peanuts onto a
plane
so i thought that was a whole other
thing so i don't know if he was half
kidding about that they didn't give us
peanuts but i assume someone might have
brought peanuts on and would casually be
eating one
peanut at a time but it's like are you
gonna list out how
and when we can eat certain things and
actually the answer to that is yes
because let's not forget that ridiculous
buffoon in new york andrew cuomo who
killed all those old people
by sending them back into the into the
old age homes
uh he also announced at one point that
wings
chicken wings don't count as a meal
because he didn't want people eating
chicken wings at bars
these people have just run rough shot
over everything that is sane
or would be considered normal as they
talk about
normality um we got to make some
decisions here
and i think we are going to continue to
see mass migrations into different
states
we're going to see some things that work
some things that don't one of the last
stories i did before
i left for florida was how florida
despite that second oldest population
that they have one of the lowest deaths
per 100 000 people
they're now vaccinating older people and
you can even see by the way
things are going so well in florida that
you can see the mainstream media right
now trying to turn
on desantis you can really see it oh and
i want to say one other thing
about desantis oh and just the general
state of people of florida people are
happy
they're happy i'm here in l.a these two
guys in the room relatively happy but
everyone here is miserable these are
miserable people and you just have to
figure it out by the look in their eyes
because you can't see their face
but people in florida they've said oh we
put a little
a little extra primacy on living freely
we want to have a little bit of a risk
so my last night in florida i went to an
indoor bar i sat
david and i sat around it was like like
a c-shaped bar
with a whole bunch of strangers we all
started talking there were people from
all over the world and then
from all over the country i should say
and then there were a couple local
floridian people and again these were
older people and they
made the decision to go out and do what
they want
for themselves that seems right to me as
opposed
to having gavin newsom or andrew cuomo
do it but but on the desantis front real
quick
you know desantis who's obviously done
it in my humble estimation
a great job with this whole thing not
only do you see the media turning on him
but now there's all these articles about
how he could be the
the florida front runner for 2024. one
of the
things that i heard in florida somebody
said this to me that what happens if
desantis runs for president in 2024
and then trump runs for governor of
florida that would be
that would be something oh you like that
one that that would be something right
there
but one of the interesting things that i
think we're going to have to see on
desantis is he's obviously a fighter he
knows what he believes in all
all of that good stuff i think he's also
younger i think he's 46 that's two years
older than me
you know we're used to having these
ancient politicians trump 74 biden 78
pelosi's 106. schumer's in his late 70s
you know what i mean like we're used to
having
uh well dianne feinstein my senator here
she's she's older than the crypt keeper
um we have to sort of let those people
move on
go into retirement like why do you still
want to control everybody at that age
um so i think that that's good that
desantis would be an actual gen xer in
some level of power
but what will be interesting is as the
media hits keep
coming and they'll tell you he's far
right and he's a white supremacist and
he hates
black people and all of the nonsense
that we all know is not true
it'll be interesting to see what degree
of sort of the trump
kind of fight back he has to use right
because
you know a lot of people said well i
like the i like the trump policies i
didn't like the person and i
i can fully understand that right i
fully understand that
but at some point when the machine
starts coming for you desantis may have
to start fighting the machine even
harder
which would be sort of a trump style
move and it'll just be interesting to
see his evolution there
so i'm just mentioning this now as a
little as a little
marker because as we see this guy's
popularity rise for good reasons
you're going to see more and more
hippies as we're just seeing him in the
last little bit
uh guys before we move on let me talk to
you about expressvpn
let there be no doubt people big tech in
the far left have joined forces to purge
america
of conservative and i would say actually
anyone non-woke
at this point and you guys all know all
about that that's exactly why i started
locals.com
so why exactly are we choosing to give
these big tech companies all of our
personal data
good question the battle lines have been
drawn big tech has made it clear which
side they're on now is the time to take
a stance
protect your personal data from big tech
with the vpn i trust
my online protection i use it myself
expressvpn
see every device whether you're on your
phone laptop or tv has a unique string
of numbers called an ip address
when you search for stuff watch videos
or even click on a link the big tech
companies can use that ip to track all
of your activity
and tie it back to you excuse me when
you use
expressvpn my connection gets or your
connection will get rerouted
through their secure encrypted servers
so that the companies can't see your ip
address at all
my internet activity becomes anonymized
and my network data is encrypted and the
best part is you don't need to be tech
savvy
at all to use expressvpn just download
the app on your phone or computer
tap one button it turns green and you're
good to go so stop handing over your
data to big tech companies whose aim is
to censor and spy on you defend your
rights
and protect your internet activity with
the vpn i use every day
that's expressvpn.comruben that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v
as in victor pn.com to get
an extra three months absolutely free go
to expressvpn.com
reuben right now to learn more all right
well speaking of big tech this is
actually a perfect segue i wasn't even
planning that
but we got a segway people uh poland
you may have heard of the country poland
and i believe there's been a few jokes
written about the polish people over the
years
well they're doing something right
because they've basically had it
with big tech you know and and this is
going to be one of the shifts that i
think we're really going to see
in 2020 and it's something i'm really
focusing on and actually
uh much of my my forthcoming book that
i'm working on right now is going to be
about this
that it we may have passed the time to
talk and now we got to be
what are the actions people can take in
their lives to fix these things what are
the
what are the concrete steps that they
can do whether that
is building new products building new
institutions
finding new jobs whatever that might be
in your life
well poland is actually doing something
because all we really do here is
complain about big tech not
i i've done a little bit more than that
but most of us just complained about
these things
uh but poland uh has had it and they
don't want
uh social media to be censored anymore
and we've got a couple quotes here from
deputy polish justice minister sebastian
kaletta and i think this guy gets it he
says
we see that when big tech decides to
remove content for political purposes
it's mostly content which praises
traditional values
or praises conservatism and it is
deleted
under their quote hate speech policy
when it has no legal right to do so he
goes on freedom of speech is not
something that anonymous moderators
working for private companies
should decide instead that is for the
national body duly elected officials in
all
industries car phones finance were
unregulated till they grew too large
the same should happen with big tech
if big tech sees themselves as an
organization empowered enough
to ban a sitting president of the united
states
it sends a message to the world that we
can ban anyone
whenever we want all right sebastian
deputy minister over in poland uh yeah
you're right and we've got to start
making decisions on this and
quick look we can rehash all of the
arguments do you just let the absolute
unfettered free market solve some of
this i think there's a
philosophic argument there that makes
sense do you need
some level of uh either regulation a lot
of people want that you know my feelings
of this i don't need some dingbat
middle management government regulator
going to google and being like
guys let me see the algorithm like that
that i don't think is going to work
could you have some anti-trust things
where you have to break up
these giant companies again i don't like
using the foot
of the government to do all those things
but we are in such
an extraordinary time where
the power that these companies have is
so
colossally unbelievable that if we don't
do anything
then people will say okay well it's not
the government congress speech the
government will be irrelevant
the government will be absolutely
irrelevant i mean think about it this
way at this point
who has more to do with your day-to-day
life
you guy watching this right now who has
more to do with your daily day-to-day
life is it
the u.s government or is it twitter and
youtube and facebook and everything else
you're watching this on youtube right
now
you're commuting communicating all day
on your phone right
like they have a tremendous amount of
power and
the maybe the ship sailed i mean i think
that's possible too maybe the chance
to do anything about any of this hash
has sailed
i would say you know look there's
there's some stuff on the horizon i can
tell you
after meeting with a lot of tech people
and and building a tech company
there's some really cool stuff on the
horizon and i don't have to tell you all
about
bitcoin and how that's blowing up right
now i think it's at like 52
000 bucks right now like pretty amazing
but there's all sorts of decentralized
storage things in the works and all of
these things that eventually
will free us more i mean
decentralization is is the future
for all of this right and that's that's
much more of a libertarian
sort of bottom-up way of looking at the
internet rather than these big companies
telling us what to do
but anyway i wanted to do this story
because i thought it was interesting
that at least
another country in this case poland is
saying we're going to figure out
some ways to deal with these companies
whether that means banning
i mean you don't want facebook banned i
suppose in poland but whatever
whatever each individual sovereign
nation has to do
to protect its citizens because he does
make a good point
we know this look what just happened in
australia the last couple days if you
guys were tracking this story facebook
just banned a whole
boatload of really so i would say
moderate in most cases uh political
sites including
uh quillette i've had claire lehmann on
from colette
um you know they do a lot on free
thought and classical liberalism and
things like that they've wrote
they've written what i would say are a
couple hit pieces on me we're gonna try
to get them on locals
okay so there's there's a lot happening
here
there's a lot happening here and uh you
know
let countries make some decisions for
themselves instead of big tech just
ruling us all
instead of one ring to rule us all let's
talk about one more back here in the
united states because
uh this administration is pretty
horrible i think that's fairly obvious
for almost anyone at this point so you
know you've got your far left activists
that i suppose
are kind of happy but not fully happy
because biden's not full woke
then you have your sort of marginal
democrat liberals who are like oh
biden's too woke for us and we're
getting back into all of these
bad deals and like a lot of weird stuff
but i thought that this video
uh was was particularly telling if you
want to know
sort of what the administration thinks
of of business of free markets
and basically of of you the people what
do they think
of you this is democrat representative
he's a democrat from
california roe kahana on cnn talking
about
the 15 minimum wage let's take a look
well of course large businesses like
amazon
and mcdonald's for example can can and
perhaps should pay more
but i'm wondering what is your plan for
smaller businesses how does this in your
view affect
mom and pop businesses who are just
struggling to keep their doors open keep
workers on the payroll right now
well they shouldn't be doing it by
paying people low wages we don't want
uh low-wage businesses i think most
successful small businesses can pay
a fair wage if you look at the minimum
wage it increased with worker
productivity until 1968
and that relationship was severed if
workers were actually getting paid
for the value they were creating it
would be up to 23
so i love small businesses i'm all for
it but i don't want small businesses
that are underpaying
employees it's fair for people to be
making
what they're producing and i think 15 is
very reasonable in this kind
okay i want nothing to do with that
person or that line of thinking
what right does this representative this
democratic representative
have to tell businesses how much they
can pay people
i've said this before but you know i get
probably hundreds of emails a week
people that want to intern for us that
want to work for us
and many of them often these people are
adults sometimes retired people who say
they want to work for us for free well
first off i pay all my interns i pay all
my guys we pay
100 of their health insurance and i know
that by paying them
and taking care of them they will work
harder that'll make a better product and
more of you will watch it will help our
economic engine grow
these are basic obvious truths when he
says
we don't want low-wage businesses
well i would prefer i suppose that every
business pay everybody as much as
possible
but you think you row kahana you think
you get to decide what businesses can do
you know not every job is worth 15
an hour and by the way i mean it's so
stupid it's extraordinary so first off
just the person
that's you know the the cash register
guy at
mcdonald's or the fry flipper which is
always the example
that people use that's probably not
worth 15
an hour right like the business has to
look at the books and go okay we have to
make this many fries this many burgers
we want to keep costs down so we get
more people to come in
and we have to look at that the guy the
idea that the government would just come
in and say no
you have to pay these people this much
that's how much this is worth
well then congratulations what's
mcdonald's gonna do they're gonna raise
the prices on all the stuff and then
what are they also gonna do well you
guys know this already they're gonna put
ipads
everywhere so that when you go to
mcdonald's or burger king or anyone else
you don't even see humans
and then there's just one guy in the
back that maybe is doing something and
he'll be replaced by a robot
soon too enough uh two soon enough he
will as well
anyway i think you you all get the point
of this like this guy comes in and this
is what progressives think they can do
with everything
they just want things to be good so that
the world should bend to what they want
it has nothing to do with math
it has nothing to do with uh economics
these are probably racist things i'm
sure he would say that as well
um but these people should have just
nothing to do with your life i mean
these people are
absolutely ridiculous and we don't want
low-wage businesses
think how insane that is so you if you
have a little startup you know you're a
kid right now if you're if you're a
young person watching this and you're
watching the whole world melt in front
of you
and you've just got a good idea whatever
that idea is you're going to make some
t-shirts and mail them out
whatever it is that you're going to do
and then you could get your friends to
be involved and then you could go oh you
know i made
400 bucks this month and i'm going to
give each of you 20 bucks well he
wouldn't want that he wouldn't want that
because he didn't give him 15
an hour we don't want those kind of
small businesses so when he's saying oh
we don't want them paying this unfair
wage
what he means is do what we want or we
will come get you
i don't like you people i don't like you
very much and uh i don't like living in
the same state as you and i'm gonna have
to do some serious thinking about that
okay you see what i'm saying
uh anyway guys uh my interview with
heather mcdonald she is like the best of
the best when it comes to just blowing
a lot of this diversity delusion
nonsense that was the title of her last
book out of the water just such a great
clear thinker
uh that full episode is up now my guest
this week you may have heard of him this
stephen crowder guy he has not been on
the show for
literally about five years which is just
absolutely crazy i had him on right at
the beginning and and
has has not been on since uh he's got
some lawsuits related to the big tech
stuff coming so we're going to talk to
crowder this week and of course if you
want direct access to me if you want to
see our videos without ads
and if you want to see all sorts of
interesting bonus stuff join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
have a great day everybody i will be
back tomorrow